first you want to understand the
business cause if you're not making
money if you're not responding to where
the business needs to grow and to the
culture that the business is promoting
then the solution might be the wrong one
second you want to understand
engineering the technology is what makes
the ideas come to life so without
understanding where the technology said
and what the team is able to deliver it
kind of doesn't matter right that's it
right okay so we covered the business
perspective and then we call it the
technology what's missing what do you
think is the third perspective the users
that's right okay if there's something
that's important in design solution it
is who it is for the designers and the
whole team need to understand who are
the potential users and what are their
needs when a circle problem in this
manner and you look at it from all
perspectives business technology design
you're creating a more holistic approach
so that the solutions that come give
wisdom to them that they're not rushed
that they're better targeted and what
would you say is the most important
thing in this stage I think in this
stage it's important to hear different
perspectives if you are over focusing on
one and not the other you might have a
solution that's lopsided so in sprint we
try to be balanced in the beginning and
hear from everyone who be involved in
making the product or who'll be involved
in approving it if you're in a large
company this may be the director of the
product the product and the director of
engineering as they represent the
business in the technology
similarly the user researchers or the
marketing and sales teams now if you're
in the startup you might not have a
person representing every single
perspective you could be this single
person in the startup you often know
wearing all these different hats so it's
useful to consider and pause even if
you're one person or even if you're a
small team that doesn't have diversified
roles yet what are the perspectives on
this problem is looking at it from a
business perspective there's one set of
issues that are important those are
about the metrics the goals the revenue
looking from a technology perspective
is another set of problems that is
generally what is the core able to do
where where are the features that are
being developed what's available to
outsource or what API is available to
bring in and then from a design
perspective it's about what are the user
needs that you want to address when you
look at it from these three perspectives
even if you have a small team you're
helping people stretch their minds
they're really opening up so that they
can consider and not miss out on a good
idea right and what could go wrong in
this stage Oh a great question often I
see teams take a very long time in this
stage if the team doesn't know each
other well this may be a rare
opportunity for them to start talking to
each other and they're so excited to
learn from each other that the stage can
drag on and take two or three hours the
goal of the spring is to understand but
then quickly move towards the other
stages in which people are defining a
strategy and starting to make things so
what could go wrong is the team can
spend too long in the stage right so
they could be like circling around until
they understand and never get to
understanding right right the the the
what could go wrong is that they could
be like really circling another thing
the code that could go wrong which is
actually a chance for something to go
right is that the challenge might be
improperly defined sometimes people who
are beginners in the art of being a
sprint master approach the challenge in
a very specific way and when they offer
to the team they learn that actually the
team has a different needs and there's
something else it's more important to
solve that is a mistake that's easier to
correct in the beginning of the sprint
and not during this phase but if if a
sprint leader finds themselves
confronted with the team that says we
should be solving something else it is a
great opportunity to seek to understand
open new years and help you team agree
on what is the right thing to do quickly
very cool so what I hear from you is
that the basic of this stage is to
understand to understand the business to
understand technology and to understand
your users that's right